[Musique]
come and get me come and get
me don't worry I can shoot you with my
ball now we're going to end the video
goodbye guys um this is the person who
do the video with
[Musique]
me
on est à la limite de l'état indien et
dans ce quartier très résidentiel de
Southfields il y a cette fumée assez
épaisse qui s'échappe d'un jardin avec
surtout une odeur vraiment vraiment
étrange et lorsque les pompiers arrivent
il toquent à la porte de la maison et là
c'est qui ouvre et qui leur dit le plus
simplement du monde que sur son barbecue
est en train de cuire un
mouton et c'est lorsque les pompiers
veulent éteindre ce feu qu'il commencent
à découvrir un nez un pied une main des
restes humains Sabrina Quider va arriver
sur les lieux chez elle et va demander
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai rien à voir
dans cette affaire-
làà mais l'enquête de voisinage va
déterminer que il y avait une jeune
fille au Père Sophie Dionet qui habitait
avec avec eux et dont on a bizarrement
plus trace déjà depuis depuis quelques
[Musique]
semaines bonjour Maman je t'envoie un
petit coucou depuis Londres en espérant
que tu vas bien ainsi que tout le
monde perso je vais super
bien le corps d'une jeune troyenne de 21
ans retrouver calciné à Londres en
Angleterre la jeune fille s'occupait des
deux enfants d'un couple
franco-algérien bon le manque de la
famille et mes amis se fait sentir ou
plutôt ressentir mais sinon je vais
super bien elle était devenue
prisonnière et n'avait pas d'autre choix
que de subir tout subir jusqu'à la
mort je découvre plein de choses ici
plein de choses que j'aime mais bon je
vais pas tarder à rentrer car parfois je
craque et puis je vais pas faire ma vie
ici non plus hein B from London
[Musique]
Sophie
en criminologie on a des degrés de
victimes on a des victimes à Baris y
risque
risque on peut tous être une victime
potentielle de
[Musique]
quelqu'un est-ce que Sophie était
quelque part une victime idéale pour
Sabrina Sophie a été la victime
d'une d'une vision d'une espèce
d'hologramme idéal qui s'est présenté
face à elle et qui lui a promis une
nouvelle
[Musique]
vie આ Mel crowner I'm 42 years old I Met
Sopi એ a customer first time coming to
my
shopપ everyone knows me as wellell run a
businessiness which is fish and chips
tradશનal dis forર
engંlish it's a very peaceful neborhood
friendendly neighborhood as
wellell
[Musique]
om
confidence Sophie c'est une jeune fille
qui est très calme très douce c'est une
rêveuse c'est une personne introvertie
qui veut changer de vie parce que c'est
aussi de son
âge le jour où elle se retrouve face à
Sabrina qu'est-ce qu'elle voit elle voit
quelqu'un qui est radicalement son
opposé c'està-dire une jeune femme qui
semble en apparence sûr d'elle qui qui
est spontané qui n'a pas peur de dire
les choses qui est tout à fait charmante
Sabrina was simil a
super all the time glamous and everybody
was adming all the time
[Musique]
en fait sopie était sous la coupe de
Sabrina ce que Sabrina veut en public
c'est
paraîtreun est trêé c'est une personne
qui est vue comme une femme étant très
sympathique très joviale donc elle fait
attention à tout ça mais d qu'elle est
contrariée
elle peut se montrer sous un autre
jour as US
sopie particular day Sophie was crying
when I ask her why you crying she said
the butter
Frid
[Musique]
elle était à bout c'était de plus en
plus intense le ton montait plus fort
elle se ramassait des claques et des
claques et des
claques she was isolated
from and had no choice to
place c'est tout le mystère de de ce
dossier c'est-à-dire que
Sophie elle aurait pu partir elle était
libre d'aller venir quand même de la
maison à l'extérieur mais
elle n'est pas
partie peut-être que rentrer c'est dire
j'ai
échoué
[Musique]
la chambre un petit peu changé mais j'ai
laissé ses
affaires j'ai remodulé un petit peu sa
chambre pour pouvoir lui faire un petit
mémorial les jours où je ne peux pas
aller au
cimetière donc sa première photo à la
maternelle et sa dernière photo au lycée
et là c'était une petite petite
fripouille là on a l'impression que
c'est une petite
[Musique]
chipie cette B là ils l'ont retiré du
doigt de Sophie le jour où le corps de
Sophie a été retrouvé dans les cendres
il me l'a nettoyé l'agent policier parce
que c'est lui qui l'a retiré c'est lui
qui l'a nettoyé il m'a demandé si je la
voulais je lui ai dit oui je la veux
c'est ma fille c'est tout ce qui me
reste de ma fille en fin de
[Musique]
compte Sophie a toujours eu la joie de
vivre elle aimait jouer s'amuser rigoler
plaisanté
elle aimait la musique elle faisait des
dessins ado c'était une personne très
gentille très sérieuse je dirais
qu'alement un petit peu de maturité
réservé aussi
elle était adorable c'est c'est une
fille que toutes ces toutes copines
rêvent d'avoir toutes copine
oui à 16 ans rien n'est compliqué mais
rien n'est facile non
[Musique]
plus je sais pas si j'en aurais beaucoup
à couvrir comme ça mais c'est c'est une
histoire vraiment particulière c'est je
dis pas que c'est l'histoire du du d'une
carrière mais c'est une histoire que que
tu traites pas à la légère et que te
poursuitis et là tu touches vraiment
l'humain aussi et tu touches le côté un
peu un peu un peu bargeot quoi un peu un
peu barré
[Musique]
je m'appelle Willy Bard je suis
rédacteur en chef délégué du journal
[Musique]
l'estclair Le Quotidien du nado ici
c'est un quotidien j'allais dire assez
calme il y a pas une vie culturelle
extrêmement développée non
plus ça tourne quand même beaucoup
autour de l'école autour du collège
lycé
[Musique]
essentiellement mes vrais amis ont
toujours été là pour moi dans les
moments de joie ou les plus difficiles
ils sont toujours là pour faire la fête
les fous les délires de gamin qui nous
font bien
rire il se foutent pas de ma
tête ne cherche pas la guerre à juger
les autres j'ai rencontré Sophie comme
ça en fait
j'ai pris sa défense par rapport à une
insulte qu'elle avait reçu
elle était là elle était dans son co
elle encaissa elle encaiss elle encaissa
et je voyais que ça commençait elle
avait les larmes aux yeux donc moi en
fait ça m'a rendu tellement folle que je
suis rentrée dans la personne en fait je
l'ai frappé sans le vouloir en fait et
c'est comme ça que notre lien d'amitié
s'est
créé et sopie a commencé à me
présenterah son groupe de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était CIN donc moi Sophie Noémie
perine et Océane je m'appelle Ophélie
j'ai 24 ans et je connais Sophie depuis
le
lycée je connaissais du coup vu qu'elle
est
partie l'entre MH et 2 on est allit dans
le bâtiment h
bah on discute nos galères amoureuses
enfin le genre de confidence qu'on fait
quand on est quand des adolescent on se
disait tout comment ça se passe les
cours bon ça va c'était les garçons
c'était cétait oh bah lui il me plaît ou
lui il me plaît enfin voilà les trucs
comme ça enfin genre c'était notre
confidente mais elle avait un peu de mal
elle à se livrer en retour à
être bah à se confier à nous quand elle
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
elle gardait souvent des choses pour
elle avec moi elle était plutôt distante
elle elle parlait
mais je dirais que c'était quand même
assez difficile je pense qu'elle avait
du mal à à parler avec moi de de ce
qu'elle pensait de ses
envies mais on avait un très bon contact
même si au niveau des paroles il y avait
pas beaucoup
de de lien
dimanche 5 août
2012 aujourd'hui que puis-je te dire et
par où commencer voilà mon beau-père a
encore pété les plombs hier soir et j'en
ai sérieusement marre j'en ai marre de
le voir faire souffrir ma mère je veux
qu'il dégage de chez nous tout ça ça
m'énerve c'est bon là
quoi j'ai un mari qui avait
tendance à boire et il suffit qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
pour que Ben tout de suite ça éclate
c'était plutôt des mots euh euh bah que
je faisais rien j'étais une incapable
j'étais une mauvaise mère tu fout rien
tu sais pas faire à manger tu sais pas
faire l'amour tu es une mauvaise femme
tu es une mauvaise épouse puis ta fille
elle fut
[Musique]
rien Sophie c'est une jeune fille très
sensible on peut comprendre que cette
jeune fille qui est plus plus sensible
que les autres puissent être marqué
davantage par un climat familial
compliqué qui peut être potentiellement
violent ça va l'atteindre beaucoup donc
elle a besoin d'air frais elle a besoin
de nouveautés elle a besoin de de rêve
éveillé j'ai retrouvé le sourire je
crois que de nouveau la vie à plein dent
ce 29 juin 2012 a changé ma vie et je te
remercie quand j'étais dans tes bras
j'étais tellement bien je me sentais
protégé c'était son premier petit cop
un vrai copain en tout cas ils étaient
très tendres tous les deux l'un envers
l'autre toujours dans dans dans les bras
se tenir la main se faire les
bisous c'était ici qui se retrouvait
tous les deux le plus
[Applaudissements]
elle était libérée se sentait bien elle
se sentait légère une plume elle se
laissait porter par la glace
elle se sentait amoureuse elle se
sentait aimée comprise in love de lui
quoi je sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais
ça c'est
fini donc après elle a eu du mal à se
remettre je pense un petit peu quand
même il y a des jours comme ça où rien
ne va tu déprimes tu penses qu'à une
chose le suicide te mutiler les bras on
dit que la vie est belle c'est avoir la
belle vie c'est tomber amoureuse et te
fracasser la gueule par la
suite une fois j'étis laavir dans sa
chambre elle était sur son lit et elle
pleurait elle se pleurait et je lui
demandais pourquoi et euh bah ça va pas
je suis pas bien bah dis-moi pourquoi je
suis là pour toi pour te rassurer tu
sais bien je je suis ta maman oui mais
je voulais pas t'embêt avec ça et puis
après elle a mis ses écouteurs et elle
écoutit ses
[Musique]
musiques
voilà je vous présente mon idole ma mère
cette femme fait mon bonheur quand je
vais pas bien une seule chanson d'elle
me suffit à me rendre mon sourire parce
que oui entendre sa [__] de magnifique
voix me redonne le sourire milen Farmer
plus qu'une simple chanteuse mon idole
ma vie ma
mère c'était quoi son rêve à
[Musique]
op son rêve c'était pouvoir de
elle avait elle avait beaucoup de choses
en tête elle écrivait très bien puis
elle regardait beaucoup de films et tout
ça donc elle adorait elle aurait bien
aimé en tout cas faire ce métier là je
pense 23 janvier 2015 vous êtes
réalisateur vous cherchez des
figurins moi je cherche des castings des
auditions et cetera n'hésitez pas à me
contacter en
privé
c'est une façon pour elle d'échapper à
son quotidien il est tout à fait normal
dans la vie d'un adolescent ou d'une
adolescente de se projeter de de de
visualiser un avenir nouvelle place dans
ce monde mais entre les rêves qu'elle
nourrit et le contexte dans lequel elle
vit il y a un décalage le cinéma je lui
ai dit de laisser tomber toi tu es
quelqu'un de discrète de renfermé pas
assez pas assez mature et je lui dis bah
pourquoi tu essayes pas les enfants
tu tu vois tu aimes bien les enfants ils
viennent tous vers toi elle me dit bah
oui maman tu as raison pourquoi
pas et un jour elle m'annonce que elle
aurait peut-être trouvé du travail mais
que ça serait pas en
France c'est à Londres c'est pour garder
des enfants c'est pour faire nous au
père et quelques jours après elle m'a
dit M Mo je m'en
vais et euh de là j'étais pas pas du
tout d'accord avec elle euh j'ai tu as
tout préparé non j'ai rien préparé mais
je m'en vais quand même on est parti un
petit peu
[Musique]
fâché c'est c'est une image qui me qui
me marquera tout le temps tout le
temps on va la mettre à genou et on va
la filmer et c'est là qu'il va y avoir
encore un nouveau déchaînement de
[Applaudissements]
violence donc on est parti un petit peu
fâché est parti à pied on a été jusque à
la gare à pied d'ici il y a pas loin il
y a quoi de
km ça ne m'avait pas étonné quand elle
avait dit qu'elle allait à
long on comprenait qu'elle voulait
changer d'air çait allit découvrir le
monde elle éta un peu voilà dans
l'aventure elle VI
l'aventure Sophie c'est une
rêveuse il y a beaucoup de gens qui
peuvent rêver leur vie sans jamais
passer à l'action et elle elle a passé
un Pact avec elle même qu'elle a
respecté c'est une jeune fille qui qui a
une très forte personnalité au final et
ça aurait été bien que quelqu'un lui
dise à
[Musique]
Sophie
21 février 2016
0h21 ce soir on a mangé à 19h30 on a
mangé un grtin de pâte à la crème de
tomate et là il est 23h15 donc 0h15 en
France et on est en train de regarder un
film accompagné de
pop-corn nous allons à la plage la
semaine prochaine ici tout va
bien bah je la sentais bien oui je
sentais qu'elle oui qu'elle était un peu
plus épanouie que son travail ben lui
plaisait beaucoup 8 juin 2016 1h55 du
matin bonsoir maman dans la semaine nous
devons voir des agences pour montrer
photos du petit shooting qui a été fait
quand j'ai été coiffé et maquillé par
[Musique]
Sabrina Sabrina disait qu'elle
travaillait dans la mode et quelque part
sophie trouve en Sabrina j'allais dire
une sorte de modèle quelqu'un qui peut
peut-être lui permettre de réaliser son
rêve on m'a proposé de tourner dans un
film aux États-Unis auprès d'un acteur
très connu mais chut je t'ai rien dit le
tournage devrait durer un peu plus d'un
an presque 2 ans qu'il m'ont dit
le concept d'emprise c'est vraiment
avoir une vision de tout ce que fait la
victime c'est-à-dire d'être là à chaque
étape d'être omniprésent dans sa
tête Sabrina a bien compris que c'était
une jeune fille qui qui avait peut-être
besoin de de de sortir de son quotidien
qui aimait l'univers artistique et elle
lui propose de l'intégrer dans ce monde
de la sortir de la maquiller d'en faire
presque sa propre fille et on ne sait
pas si Sabrina il y a peu de chance P
qu'à ce moment-là elle voulait lui faire
du mal le le trouble est probablement
arrivé après mais elle a dit les mots
qu'une jeune fille de 19 ans a envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'entendre bah disons qu'au fil du temps
les nouvelles oui se sont estompées
progressivement bon je m'inquiétais pas
beaucoup puisque elle était là-bas pour
travailler donc moi je l' laissé euh à
son travail c'était très très difficile
à la contacter ça a été très difficile
pourquoi pas le temps tout le temps
occupé pas le temps euh elle répondait
soit de TR jours après soit une semaine
après was stuck down full
time
doing big
r has do the cleaning the cooking the
laundry Sho
Groc à aucun moment elle m'a dit ça va
pas je suis mal jamais jamais jamais
jamais Sophie c'est quelqu'un qui
cherche avant tout à
rassurer donc lorsqu'elle dit tout va
bien à ce maman lorsqu'elle dit tout va
bien ses amis pour que le discours soit
cohérent tout va bien elle ne veut pas
inquiéter c'est quelqu'un qui ne veut
pas être s'imposer dans la vie des
autres never
paid tick France
par money will
that you paid you Canay me back but I
get a respon from her saying to take
this opportunity fly
peut-être que Sophie elle y croit encore
à ce momentl SAF qu' un moment donné
Sophie comprend bien on voit bien dans
les échanges qu'elle avec sa
maman il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
du côté de
[Musique]
Sabrina elle dit qu'elle en a rien à
faire de ma famille elle m'accuse
d'avoir volé un pendantif avec un
diamant très précieux elle laa pendtif
revenu à sa
place que Sabrina soit quelqu'un qui en
apparence soit sympathique chaleureuse
loca spontané c'est comme ça qu'elle est
effectivement décrite n'empêche pas que
derrière elle a elle peut avoir une
autre
personnalité Sabrina elle souffre d'un
d'un trouble paranoïque c'est une femme
qui s'invente des films et elle donne le
rôle le rôle de Sophie c'est quelqu'un
de mauvais c'est l'ennemi à abattre
petit à petit Sabrina va commencer à lui
reprocher des tas de choses qu'elle sait
pas s'occuper des enfants elle sait pas
faire manger des brimades des
accusations à se voir traiter de tous
les noms Sophie devient la bête noire de
Sabrina c'est l'ennemi dans sa maison
mais au lieu de la faire sortir elle la
maintient dans son délire de persécution
ce délire
paranoïque un femux soir vers 4h du
matin je tente un coup de bouur j'ess de
la jour et me
répond je posé la question est-ce que
les enfants sont pas trop dur est-ce que
c'est cool est-ce que tes employeurs ça
va mais elle me répondait pas
franchement en fait comme si elle avait
peur en fait son employeur était à côté
et je l'ai vu elle entendait tout notre
conversation c'est pour ça peut-être que
Sophie était souriante et qu'elle ne
disait
rien
[Musique]
dis à ce moment-là sabrina est au
paroxisme de son délire envers Sophie
arrête de mentir [__] tuas emmené mon
fils oui ou non Sabrina va reprocher à
Sophie d'avoir emmené son fils dans une
maison où l'attendait un gros gaillard
tatoué pour justement abuser
sexuellement de leur fils av avant de le
ramener tranquillement à la maison on va
retrouver 18 fichiers audio sur 3
semaines à chaque fois quelques quelques
minutes tu te fous de moi c'est ça et
ils ont conservé ces enregistrement là
ils ont tout conservé sur leur téléphone
portable arrête de mentir Sophie tu as
emmené mon fils arrête de mentir [__]
tu as emmené mon fils oui ou non
est là je t'écoute combien de fois il
est venu combien de fois la nuit allez
combien de fois il est venu je vais te
tuer je vais te tuer
dépêche-toi qui est l'homme dont parle
Sabrina dans les
enregistrements alors Mar Welton est le
fondateur de boyone groupe de band
irlandais dans les années 90 qui a fait
fortune une vraie passion entre Mark
Welton et Sabrina Quider de laquelle
naîtra un petit
[Musique]
garçon le couple n'a pas duré longtemps
et de fait elle a commencé à développer
une obsession envers
lui lui reprochant des tas de choses des
abus sexuels sur son fils sur elle des
violences également et sabrinaider a
très vite été persuadée
que Sophie était quelque part une agent
infiltré de Mark Welton pour lui nuire
[Musique]
elle souffre d'un trouble elle a un
trouble de de probable de la
personnalité ce qui est pas forcément le
cas où il s'aime lui on pourrait dire
qu'il a un trouble délirant induit il
suit ce que dit sa
compagne je sais quand tu mens Sophie e
Sabrina je te
crois Sophie dis la vérité
quand on regarde la la
structure de des actions de ce couple ça
fait penser à la fameuse folie à deux on
a une personnalité dominante qui a des
croyances qu'elle va amener tout
doucement à une deuxième personnalité
qui est passive et qui va être le
réceptacle de toute cette de toutes ces
croyances et d'une pensée unique ça va
devenir une pensée
commune et puis viendra cette
dernière journée ça fait à peu près 3
semaines que Sophie n'a plus manger à sa
fin on va la mettre à genou et on va la
filmer pour dire ben voilà maintenant
fais-nous ta confession qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé exactement avec Mar
Walton c'est c'est une image qui me qui
me marquera tout le temps tout le
temps
d'ailleurs quand je l'ai vu j'ai j'ai
hurlé j'ai hlé parce que je je ma fille
je la voyait pas comme ça quoi on y
voyait le visage très
creusé on voyait on voyait tous ces
traits je voyais ses mains très très
amaigries de de de 54 kg elle devait
passer être à 35 kg 30 kg quoi en il
s'avère que ça suffit pas encore on va
l'emmener dans la salle de bain et c'est
là qu'il va y avoir encore un nouveau
déchaînement de violence on monte encore
d' d'un degré et là on va tout
simplement auemot on va la torturer en
lui mettant la tête sous l'eau dans la
dans la baignoire c'était un vendredi
matin en pleine
nuit moi je dors je dors très peu donc
j'ai entendu taper à ma
porte j'ai ouvert la porte et j'ai tout
de suite dit qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est pour Sophie qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé franchement j'ai
été bouleversé peiné j'avais envie
d'hurler mais alors vraiment d'hurler
parce
que ma fille s'est vu
mourir sous la torture elle s'est vu
mourir et ça ça fait
mal ça fait extrêmement mal de voir ses
enfants mourir comme ça sophie n'a plus
respirer ils ont allongé son corps
par terre et ils ont pris ils ont fait
le choix de l'enfermer dans une valise
et où est-ce qu'ils ont placé la valise
sous le lit des enfants en attendant de
trouver une solution pour savoir que
faire du
[Musique]
corps
le jour où j'ai appris son décès je lui
envoyé inconsciemment un
message s'il te plaît dis-moi que c'est
pas toi dis-moi que rien arrivé dis-moi
que final c'était la vérité et après
cette histoire qu'est-ce qu'elle est
devenu cette bande de copines de 5 alors
s dissoute oui c'était notre pilier
c'était une personne en or elle était
vraiment mdal enfin c'était en tout cas
une des personnes importantes dans notre
groupe
oui je l'ai pas si pris dans mes
bras et je le regrette
profondément et si c'était à refaire bah
je lui diraiis que je
l'aime comme je fais avec mes enfants
maintenant et avec mon fils je lui dis
constamment que je l'aime
aussi
[Musique]